tonight russia's defense ministry tells
ukraine it has until 5 a.m moscow time
that is 60 minutes from now
to surrender the besieged port city of
mariupol the russians adding that it
will let residents and troops who lay
down arms leave we'll give you any more
updates as they come throughout the hour
evening everyone and welcome to the next
revolution live from new york tonight
with a shocking story from the war on
our southern border how we need to
tackle the threat from china and the
scandal of joe biden's corruption and
how it was covered up by the media and
big tech in the 2020 election but we
start tonight with the question so many
americans are asking are we being
dragged into a war with russia
what should america's role be in the
horror that's unfolding in ukraine none
of this is easy there are no definitive
right answers it's about judgment and
balancing different risks so we must be
able to disagree without questioning
each other's motives if you're skeptical
about america getting involved you're
not a russian asset or a putin
propagandist and if you think we should
be involved that doesn't make you a
neocon globalist warmonger we've got to
get away from this dumb tribalism and
treat each other with good faith
here's how i see it when people say we
should be focused on our problems at
home i completely agree that is the
first responsibility of government but i
don't think anyone is seriously arguing
that america should just not have a
foreign policy ignore it when a nuclear
power brutally invades another country
the question is what response is in our
interests people say our leaders
shouldn't send other people's kids to
die in wars where american interests
aren't clear i couldn't agree more
and it was a recent example of that
which makes so many americans suspicious
of what's going on now america's leaders
did send other people's kids to die in a
war where america's interests weren't
clear they invaded iraq manufactured the
justification lied about the threat to
america corruptly enrich themselves on
the back of it all but does that one
terrible example mean america should
avoid any foreign conflict should we
really have let bin laden and al qaeda
go unpunished for 9 11. that was why we
went to war in afghanistan yes it went
on 19 years too long but at the start it
was totally justified
going back further hitler never attacked
america but does anyone seriously think
it was wrong to fight and defeat him
surely that's one of the proudest
moments in america's history and it
helped lay the foundation for decades of
american leadership and prosperity
what about the cold war was it wrong for
reagan to fight the evil empire as he
called it it wasn't just his military
build up at home reagan took the fight
to the soviets he armed the afghan
resistance so the russian army was stuck
in a quagmire for a decade that led
directly to the fall of the soviet union
and the defeat of communism was reagan
wrong to do all that what about the gulf
war kicking saddam hussein out of kuwait
remember storm in norman schwarzkopf we
were proud of that weren't we it was
actually margaret thatcher who pushed
president bush to do it was she wrong
should a dictator's aggression have been
allowed to stand
i just can't believe most americans
really want to disown so much of
america's freedom-fighting history
america was born out of the fight for
freedom and independence and america has
become the greatest nation in the
history of the world in large part
because america has led the world and
stood up for freedom and independence
when they're threatened
it was george w bush's iraq war that was
out of step with that history
like obama's appeasement of putin
when he invaded crimea in 2014 and
obama's appeasement of syrian dictator
assad when he used chemical weapons
trump didn't make that mistake he hit
assad hard when he used chemical weapons
and it didn't happen again
trump defeated isis took out solomonia
al-baghdadi the al qaeda leader in yemen
trump wasn't an isolationist he
projected american force around the
world built up our military after years
of decline
america first didn't mean america
isolated staying at home
america first meant america leading
but in smart ways not stupid ones
getting results and then getting out
that is totally different from the
neocon ideology the delusional messianic
attempt to remake the world according to
some master plan written in a washington
dc think tank
that's not what we're talking about now
with ukraine and russia
this is about confronting aggression we
know how important that is right here at
home we can see what happens when we
don't confront crime we get more crime
if we react to putin like some
soros-backed d.a you know seeing it from
the criminal's point of view going easy
on them in the hope they'll just quietly
go away it is hopeless
it just incentivizes more violence
and some people might say well maybe
that's true if we stay out of this war
encourage a peace deal where putin gets
what he wants maybe that will
incentivize putin to invade some other
country or some other dictator to do the
same but as long as they're not invading
america why should we care
we should care because at that point
what you're looking at is a completely
lawless world
where rogue regimes do whatever they
want especially if they have nuclear
weapons which obviously more countries
will try and get so they can join in the
nuclear blackmail that's bad for america
just as a lawless city is bad for the
people who live there
one of the reasons america is the
world's leading nation is because
america leads
we have the world's highest living
standards because we've shaped the rules
the world lives by if we let all of that
break down if we just hand it over to
authoritarian dictatorships like russia
and china we'll end up poorer as well as
less secure
no sane person wants war but unlike the
iraq war we didn't start this one putin
did he started it because he sensed
american weakness after trump left
office biden lifting sanctions on the
nordstrom pipeline killing the keystone
pipeline cutting defense spending the
surrender to the taliban all that on top
of the weakness putin saw from biden and
obama the last time he invaded ukraine
in 2014
instead of trump's peace through
strength we got war through weakness
but now we're here surely we need to
make sure america wins
because if putin wins his ally xi
jinping wins and as we've said many
times china is the real threat to our
country's future none of this means we
need to send young americans to die in
ukraine of course not in fact if we had
a smart leader in the white house
instead of a feeble old fool who's never
led on anything in his life
we would be fighting putin in ways that
actually help america
most obviously of course by unleashing
our energy industry
so that's what we're arguing for here
strong smart leadership that stands up
for freedom independence and
self-determination and strengthens our
economy and our global standing in the
process
i would really love to know what you
think i really mean that please follow
us at steve hilton x and that next drive
fnc share this message and tell us what
you think hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else